[Musique]
le
non
l'orgueil bafoués des militaires en la
signature possible la flotte allemande
voulait tenter une sortie impérial
attaqué la royale mais v en un dernier
combat imposé aux alliés une trêve et
non subir un agenouillement un combat
pour l'honneur
les marins répondent mutinerie et
hissent le drapeau rouge munich
stuttgart berlin même se réveille avec
des drapeaux rouges on proclame la
république dans les rues les bolcheviks
les socialistes tiennent le haut du pavé
était ce le voeu de wilson les soldats
et les officiers allemands demandent
tous l'abdication de keyser
périssent les hohenzollern plutôt que
l'allemagne distille
[Musique]
le kayser réfugiés au quartier général
prétend marché sur berlin la rouge avec
son armée mais vous n'avez plus d'armes
et lui dit le général grunner
[Musique]
le 10 novembre 1918 l'empereur
d'allemagne
prend le train pour la hollande un pays
neutre qui accepte de l'accueillir un
petit jardin hollandais c'est tout ce
qui lui reste de son empire les ong
lherm ne sont plus
une signature sur une lettre d'
abdication
le nouveau gouvernement du socialiste et
berthe remplace celui de max de bad qui
démissionne
le premier ordre donné par et berthe est
envoyé aux plénipotentiaires allemands
qui n'ont toujours pas signé ils
reçoivent l'instruction d'établir un
accord sauvant tout ce qui peut être
sauvé
la crainte du bolchevisme accélère les
choses des deux côtés à 5h10 du matin
les allemands signe enfin le 11 novembre
[Musique]
le cessez-le-feu confirmer désormais est
fixé à 11 heures il y a six heures de
guerre en plus les poilus dans les
tranchées doivent risquer leur vie six
heures de plus
[Musique]
six heures de plus laissé aux généraux
les britanniques attacked à mons pour
effacer la défaite de 1914 les
américains marche sur sedan qu'il
s'était fixé comme but au départ de leur
offensive un régime ambiante qui reçoit
encore des ordres d'attac à
10h55
les obus allemand donc encore sur verdun
au matin du 11 novembre
les pertes sont lourdes fait des alliés
et aussi chez des allemands
[Musique]
encore quelques minutes et tout sera
terminé
[Musique]
chacun veut avoir le plaisir de tirer sa
dernière des charges pour en finir
ce n'est pas un barrage dit un témoin
pourtant tous les cas nous tirer
ensemble
c'est un déluge de feu
m
[Musique]
rien ne se passe à 11 heures précises
explique un correspondant américain pas
de fraternisation
mes ennemis se dresse or des tranchées
et se regardent en silence
accablé par le silence
et puis on se rassemble pour manger
boire fumer pour chanter mais mes dents
c'est la fin du cauchemar
[Musique]
bah
à londres une proclamation royale
annonce la fin de la guerre le parlement
est en congé pour que ses membres
puissent assister au service action de
grâce de l'église sainte margaret aux
portes de buckingham palace à piccadilly
circus à trafalgar square la foule
laisse éclater sa joie ponctués par la
sonnerie des cloches
aux états unis où la nouvelle de
l'armistice tombe à 3 heures du matin
les gens où vont leurs fenêtres en
pyjama
quelques uns portent des masques contre
la grippe espagnole
wilson a lancé son message relayé par
radio l'impérialisme armée a vécu
[Musique]
c'est à paris que la joie explose le
plus fort on n'entend plus le bruit du
canon mais les gens qui chantent la
marseillaise même au palais bourdon dans
les rues marchandes à pied depuis sa
maison de la rue franklin jusqu'au
parlement
clemenceau est embrassée par plus de 500
femmes
[Musique]
ce jour là personne n'accorde de crédit
aux mots durs de lloyd george cette
guerre comme la prochaine est une guerre
pour en finir avec la guerre mais en
aura t'on jamais fini demande clémence
autres sceptiques
pour les français la fin de la guerre ce
n'est pas la paix c'est la victoire mais
la victoire mais malheureusement pas
suivi par la paix
[Musique]
pourtant il faut bien vers la paix pour
que la guerre ne recommence pas les
armées allemandes ont quitté le
territoire français belge et
luxembourgeois
des 11 millions d'allemands mobilisé
quatre seulement sont revenus un des
deux millions sont morts
ceux qui ont échappé rentrer chez eux en
héros
le public allemand ne veut pas croire
que son armée a été vaincu
[Musique]
les français récupèrent leurs provinces
perdues l'alsace et la lorraine province
annexée par les allemands en 1871
les autorités françaises se hâte de
revenir à metz et à strasbourg
clemenceau et poincaré entre-temps
calèche dans masse et strasbourg
pavoiser deux tricolores à metz on jette
à terre la statue géante de ligue 2
[Musique]
puis les alliés entre en allemagne trois
années d'occupation françaises
britanniques et américaines
qui prennent en otage cinq pour cent du
territoire allemand pour garantir la
paix demande bien sûr l'allemagne a
signé un armistice
il faut pouvoir la contraindre à signer
aussi la paix
à
le 4 décembre 1918 le président wilson
63 cents vêtu de l'armure du chevalier
du droit vol pour l'europe à bord du
george washington
il se rend à la conférence de la paix où
doit se régler le sort de l'allemagne de
l'europe et aussi le sort du monde
[Musique]
le président débarque à brest le 13
décembre il était le premier président
des états unis a voyagé en europe
pendant la durée de son mandat il se
présentait à la foule comme une sorte
d'évangélistes wilson était l'apôtre de
la paix du droit
[Musique]
ils passent noël avec la 77e division au
quartier général de pershing à jour mon
piercing est content de la visite
présidentielle
très content wilson séguin des c'est
montrer chaleureux avec les deux boys
qui l'ont accueilli avec joie
leur at-il promis de rentrer chez eux
très vite comme il le souhaite pour la
plupart
[Musique]
26 décembre wilson franchi le channel il
est à londres les députés s'étonne que
les républicains du sénat qui sont
contre le traité ne l'accompagnent pas
ne vous inquiétez pas de winson je suis
têtu comme une mule j'imposerai m'ont
traitée aux états unis
[Musique]
la traversée de londres en calèche avec
le roi est un triomphe partout wilson
connaît des succès populaires
[Musique]
le 2 janvier il est accueilli à rome par
le roi d'italie victor emmanuel
les migrants italiens sont très nombreux
aux états unis et c'est la première fois
qu'un président américain en exercice
vient à rob
il est accueilli avec un enthousiasme
extraordinaire
il croit que le peuple approuve sa
politique et les italiens pensent que
s'il leur rend visite c'est qu'il défend
leurs revendications le malentendu est
totale
[Musique]
il rentre à paris le 7 janvier pour
présider deux semaines plus tard dans la
capitale française les travaux de la
conférence de la paix
[Musique]
dans l'allemagne vaincue les troupes
d'occupation alliées occupent leurs
zones respectives
selon les termes précis de l'armistice
les français se souviennent des heures
de la révolution et de l'empiré et il se
conduit sans vainqueur fastueux
terrifiant tout de même les populations
par les défis des deux troupes indigènes
les sénégalais passé pendant la guerre
pour deux redoutables nettoyeur de
trancher
leur présence est mal acceptée par les
allemands
[Musique]
cologne est la capitale de la zone
britanniques
les allemands montre de la courtoisie
voire de la soumission à leurs
vainqueurs dit un témoin
[Musique]
la flotte de haute mer allemande a
cinglé sous surveillance vers les bases
britanniques selon les termes de
l'armistice
dix navires de bataille si 3h08
croiseurs légers 50 destroyer plus de
120 sous marins se sont rendus
six mois plus tard à scapa flow les
allemands se sabordera
sous contrôle extrêmement sourcilleux
les britanniques en accord avec les
résolutions du traité de versailles
le démantèlement de l'armée allemande se
poursuit les avions les ai plein sont
saisis et détruits le militarisme
allemand a vécu
[Musique]
m
on
ouais
où
[Musique]
les américains sont la troisième
puissance occupante
ils stationnent au sud de la zone
britannique autour de coblence dans
cette ville est née la dynastie des
môles que les chefs d'état-major de
l'armée prussienne ses habitants de
coblence ne recevait pas les yankees
avec plaisir mais les dum boys étaient
de bons enfants
gentils avec la jeunesse avec les filles
ils furent très vite accepté
à
les officiers américains aimait la
chasse avant toute chose le général
allen commandant de la 90e division
organisé deux superbes chasse au renard
[Musique]
les allemands ne pouvait qu'apprécier
les antennes médicales alliés qui
luttait contre la faim
le blocus alliés n'étaient toujours pas
levé et si churchill avait envoyé six
bateaux de vivre aux gens de hambourg le
jour de l'armistice les autres villes
crever de faim
l'allemagne que laisser la plus grande
famine depuis la guerre de trente ans
disait herbert hoover qui s'était rendu
célèbre en envoyant des secours à la
belgique occupe et
hoover attirer l'attention du
gouvernement américain sur les
conséquences de cette famine en
allemagne
en mars 1919 les alliés décidé de
fournir des vivres jusqu'à la récolte
éliminant talent si la famine
mais on leur reprochait amèrement de ne
pas avoir agi plus vite
[Musique]
oh
e
l'occupation dans tous les secteurs
étaient assez stricte
on voulait éviter les désordres les
attentats la révolution peut-être le
couvre-feu était instaurée dans
certaines zones on fouillait les civils
la police des routes arrêter les
voitures
les frontières étaient soigneusement
gardés
en allemagne n'ont occupé le désordre
régnait en maître
l'extrême-droite une serre et se
rassembler et l'extrême gauche tenait la
rue à berlin avec les spartakistes
proche des benchs vic russe à munich
avec les socialistes révolutionnaires
dice nerfs et berthe un socialiste
modéré rétablissez l'ordre à berlin à la
mitrailleuse pendant que s'ouvrait des
négociations de l'ape et le parti
communiste allemand à peine n'est allé
beaucoup souffrir
e
l'allemagne à cette date se préparent à
voter pour la première fois dans le
cadre d'un seul état
pendant que dans berlin la révolution
fit rage
combat tué écrasé par les mitrailleuses
de l'armée
les sociaux-démocrates l'emportent se
réunissent en assemblée nationale avait
marre et accouche d'une constitution
wilson est très content il a trouvé des
interlocuteurs légaux en allemagne
le nouveau chancelier s'appelle
scheidemann
le président s'était berthe
ils seront les signataires désigné de la
paix de versailles
en janvier 1919 la conférence de paris
est une pétaudière
orlando se plaint déjà que les alliés ne
prennent pas en compte les
revendications l'italienne
les britanniques le djordje eban fort
veulent presser le citron allemand
jusqu'au pépin les manceaux tout heureux
que la conférence se passe à paris dit
de wilson le prophète qu'ils parlent
comme dieu le père mais qu'il agit comme
l'oeil djordje l'impérialiste
[Musique]
paderewski le polonais héroïque le grand
pianiste international
est bien reçue aux états unis où la
communauté polonaise et nombreuses il
défend à versailles les droits d'une
grande colonne incluant dancing et lloyd
george d je ne voudrais pas que dans 20
ans on repart en guerre pourtant tig
parmi les autres chefs d'état le prince
fayçal introduit par lawrence d'arabie
le jeune économiste britannique john
maynard keynes âgé de 35 ans fait figure
d'oracle il estime que la paix est
totalement irréalisable et que wilson
est un tricheur le journaliste américain
walter lippmann conseillé à 29 ans le
colonel house couvre la conférence pour
le n'y aurait pas blake il abandonnera
son poste en février écoeuré par le
désordre
john foster dulles 7 à 30 ans membre de
la commission des réparations qui va
s'efforcer de faire payer l'allemagne
les quatre grands sont lloyd george
orlando clemenceau et wilson ils n'ont
nullement les mêmes préoccupations
les trois européens s'accordent à
traiter wilson d'idéalistes ignorant les
problèmes complexes de l'europe
clemenceau dit il nous a apporté ses 14
points dieu n'en avait que 10
et pourtant wilson se prend un peu pour
dieu le père c'est du moins ce qu'on lui
reproche à paris
la première séance de la conférence
avait eu lieu le 18 janvier
les revendications italienne sur
l'adriatique n'était pas admise par
wilson de tous les responsables allié le
président américain était le seul qui le
plus engagé a signé deux traités sans le
vote du sénat américain pour obtenir
l'agrément des alliés sur ce point
wilson avait dû transiger sur d'autres
allant au-devant des reproches futur des
républicains le président travail est
cependant d'arrache-pied à imposer ses
14 points aux belligérants comme base du
traité de paix
l'un des points les plus remarquables et
et la création d'une ligue des nations
qui devait prévenir tous les conflits
à l'hôtel crillon les experts de wilson
travaillé sans relâche pour incorporer
le projet de ligue des nations au traité
de paix le monde entier attend l'appétit
le secrétaire d'état a lancé le
président wilson veut sa ligue je pense
que le monde devra attendre le colonel
house est le seul à soutenir à fond
l'action de wilson à versailles
la conférence est une machine qui
grincent elle doit s'occuper en
permanence du découpage des territoires
pour faire place à la fois aux
revendications des belligérants et aux
exigences des nouvelles nations alors on
discute de la sarre de dand sig des
sudètes
wilson dégoûté par toutes ces
revendications
retourne chez lui pour un mois les
italiens se plaignent qu'on ne veut pas
leur donner fioul
le 7 mai 1919 les allemands sont reçus
sous bonne garde au trianon palace de
versailles
ils sont introduits dans la grande salle
la délégation est conduite par un
aristocrate le compte de pop d'or france
ô que clemenceau apostrophe avec vigueur
le moment est venu lui dit-il de régler
les comptes les réclamations allemandes
sont fort mal reçue en particulier de
lloyd george qui trouve insupportable et
prétentions de broc dans friends haut
les allemands rendre furieux à berlin
ils n'ont pu présenter aucune objection
ainsi prend naissance en allemagne le
mythe du diktat de versailles que les
allemands présentent comme aussi
éloignés que possible les 14 points du
président wilson
et baert qualifie publiquement le traité
de monstrueux le chancelier scheidemann
se résigne mais parle de l'assassinât
d'un peuple
brokdorf renzo le ministre des affaires
étrangères est naturellement de cet avis
il est tellement indigné qu'il
démissionne
mme ehrman muller signera sa place le
traité de versailles parce que les
allemands n'ont pas le choix
le sous-secrétaire d'état johannes belle
l'accompagnent à versailles
le 28 juin cinq ans ou presque après
l'assassinât de l'archiduc héritiers
d'autriche sarajevo
le traité de paix est en fait signer à
versailles au palais dans la galerie des
glaces lieu symbolique en 1871 bismarck
qui avait fait proclamer l empire
allemand
m
[Musique]
le document contenait en tout trente
mille mots l'allemagne devait
reconnaître sa responsabilité dans le
déclenchement de la guerre elle rendait
toutes ses colonies elle réduisait son
armée à cent mille hommes sans armes
lourdes
elle devait payer d'énormes réparation
incluant les pensions à certains anciens
combattants alliés
le total de cette masse devaient être
calculés après la conférence par une
commission
de la ligue des nations l'allemagne
était exclu
la paix était une cote mal taillée
l'allemagne était maltraitée et
cependant elle conservait toute sa
puissance industrielle et surtout la
constitution créer une unité politique
en allemagne qu'elle n'avait jamais
connu elle était libre de penser à la
revanche et de céder de nouveau aux
démons du nationalisme le patchwork des
petites nations créé en europe centrale
susciterait beaucoup de conflits que la
ligue des nations ne pourrait prévenir
65 millions d'hommes avaient été
mobilisés en quatre ans de guerre la
signature de ce traité bâclé n'avait pas
duré une heure
on
pour la première fois depuis 1914
jaillissait devant les délégués ébloui
les grandes eaux de versailles dans le
parc du château
bien commenté wilson c'est fini et si
personne n'est satisfait cela me fait
espérer que nous avons fait une juste
paix que deviendra cette paix les lieux
seuls le savent un avion symbole de
futurs passer en trombe sous l'arc de
triomphe annoncé ty la prochaine guerre
celle qui le nouveau aux minerais
l'europe wilson avait fait son devoir
il avait de son mieux régler le sort de
l'europe mais il n'avait pas éliminer la
plus grande menace celle qui venait de
l'est
[Musique]
il y a toujours des doutes boys en armes
dans la russie communiste quand wilson
signent le traité de versailles dans les
pays du froid les groupements de forces
alliées combattent les bonnes choses vic
isolés les uns des autres
soutenant des fractions armées de
l'ancien empire russe ce que les rouges
appelle les blancs
les cosaques des plaines de terrenoire
les sibériens les hommes du grand nord
cela ne veulent pas être bolchevisme
les sentinelles alliés montent la garde
les anglais gardent archangels les
français odessa les américains
vladivostok trois entrées de l'ancien
empire
[Musique]
au kremlin en 1918 le pouvoir et civils
révolutionnaire le parti que l'on
appelle désormais communiste et non plus
bolchevique domine sa nouvelle capitale
et moscou
étrange gouvernement un officier
allemand est installé dans chaque
ministère
les troupes allemandes tiennent le pays
la russie est sortie de la guerre son
chef lénine a choisi l'allemagne et
saper léonine ça pète vainqueur il a
repoussé les offres du président wilson
il a préféré jouer la carte allemande
lénine se charge de construire le régime
pendant que son camarade trotsky
organise armée rouge rup's d'ascq de
reprendre en main l'ancienne armée du
tsar de la reconstruire de l'endoctriner
de lui trouver d'autres chefs que les
officiers blancs qui depuis 1917 ont
perdu leurs épaules est le rôle de
l'armée rouge et d'être d'abord une
super police politique le restaurer la
puissance de l'état russe et de
reprendre un jour aux allemands leurs
dépouilles l'armée rouge mobilise
[Musique]
pendant que l'armée rouge se constitue
des régions entières se soulève contre
le pouvoir communiste
mais aussi contre l'occupation allemande
une armée de cosaques tient les rives du
doubs
elle obéit tout général blanc entonné
denny chin
alexandre koltchak amiral unsa
organisent la dissidence en sibérie sa
dictature militaire est impitoyable il
promet pour plus tard des réformes
démocratiques
[Musique]
la légion tchèque est la troisième force
militaire de la dissidence
60000 sommes bien armés sur le
transsibérien ces déserteurs de l'armée
austro-hongroise se sont engagés dans
les rentes saristes ils veulent regagner
l'ouest ces aventuriers deviennent pas
des plus importants éléments de la
politique de refoulement du communisme
entreprises par les chefs vallier
[Musique]
la légion tchèque attire tous les
groupes d'opposition qui ne supportent
ni les bolcheviks ni les allemands
la légion marche vers l'est le long du
transsibérien
elle veut arriver dans le port de
vladivostok
quelques tchèque ayant déjà pris
position mais les bolcheviks et les
allemands sont en mesure de couper la
voie ferrée et s'opposer au passage du
gros de la troupe
40000 tchèques sont ainsi accroché par
l'armée rouge est soutenue par les
alliés qui veulent à tout prix les
récupérer
[Musique]
l'ambassadeur des états unis à moscow
david francis est un des partisans de
l'intervention des alliés contre le
pouvoir bolchevique il décrit ce pouvoir
comme répressif terroristes les chefs
d'été ils sont les amis des allemands
les britanniques et les français ont
envoyé des troupes à vladivostok dès le
mois d'août 1918 pour eux les bolcheviks
sont l'ennemi parce qu'ils sont les amis
des allemands
churchill revenu au pouvoir pense qu'il
faut reconstituer le front russe de
guerre est donc éliminé les rouges mahdi
vostok et dans son esprit une tête de
pont il compte sur les tchèques pour la
tenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
churchill compte aussi sur le japon
allié de l'angleterre et vainqueurs des
russes en 1905
tokyo ne le fais pas dire deux fois
soixante dix mille soldats japonais sont
aussitôt expédié à vladivostok
wilson voit rouge quand on lui annonce
le débarquement des japonais ils doutent
de l'issue morale d'une telle
intervention il expédie aussitôt une
force de 70 mille marines pour
équilibrer les japonais et sauver les
tchèques mais aussi pour manifester au
peuple russe sa sympathie
pour qu'ils comprennent que les alliés
sont hostiles aux bolcheviks absolument
hostile est prêt à faire la guerre
contre eux
voilà donc les américains engagés en
russie la diva stock est elle une tête
de pont ou une zone refuge on y affiche
les drapeaux alliés est-ce pour le
départ d'une reconquête
le quartier général des alliés est en
plein désordre parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'objectifs communs les italiens les
chinois les tchèques les russes mènent
le même combat mais les chinois et les
japonais se détestent les italiens
surgissent pour participer au partage la
province mais français et les anglais
veulent marcher vers moscou et le
général américain grève refuse
washington l'a bien la verte et vaut
marcher sur des oeufs bourré dynamite
m
roger de sanglante lundi vostok ils ont
un uniforme spéciale pour l'hiver leur
boulot gardez les entrepôts tenir le
transsibérien
800 mille tonnes de surplus alliés route
et pourrissent dans les entrepôts
de l'équipement jadis expédié à l'allié
russe
on
il existe d'autres stocks de matériel et
munitions à des milliers de km de
vladivostok dans l'extrême nord de la
russie d'un accès difficile pour les
convois un allié mais aussi pour l'armée
rouge
les alliés y envoient des troupes pour
protéger leurs biens et empêcher qu'ils
ne tombent aux mains de l'ennemi
germaneau bolchevique
[Musique]
mais